ah austin texas perfect place for an
installment of change my mind
so we headed down to talk about how
antifa and black lives matter are
domestic terrorist organizations
and of course changed my mind is a time
where oh look it's wholesome [ __ ]
[Music]
you'll get to hear more from motorcycle
man and boombox boy in the full upcoming
video but for now
watch what happened when i tried to get
our resident wannabe kick-ass 2
impersonator to sit down for a friendly
chat
[Music]
since day one he does not commit crime
whatsoever so you just said that we'll
make sure that's right
no he does not commit crime before we do
anything else
he's been there since day one he's been
having my back and he does not
get assumed cool now anything else that
happens that's cool
you can do whatever you think what i'm
saying but i just want to make sure
before anybody
happens i'll go on uh you know youtube
and stuff
could you could you ask him to stop
disrupting so we can keep having
discussions i think that's productive
i appreciate it but could you ask him to
having free speech right for everybody
not just yeah the reason that i'm not
going to is because this narrative is
dangerous and this narrative got garrett
foster murdered
for y'all to say that these people out
here saying black lives matter
are domestic terrorists you're putting
lives at risk so i will not talk to you
you know what you're doing
the police report says that he did have
an ak-47 and the guy was writing for
uber
okay so i'm sorry i don't i didn't have
anything to do with garrett foster being
killed so i want to say this but just
because of that i think we might set up
shop and i actually think that that's a
valid self-defense that shooting right
there
if someone storms your car and you're
being booted while you're in your car
and someone comes up with an ak-47
aiming it in
let's change the sign
[Music]
um
but even with our new sign makeshift as
it may be no one wanted to sit down and
talk
so we decided to take a little field
[Music]
trip
[Music]
hey we're here at the uh the garrett
foster memorial
uh not that we were run out of town by
anthony rail we were there for about
i don't know they're about 45 minutes
they just we were walking off requested
that i kill myself
so that's a new i'll consider it
probably not garrett foster for people
who don't know the people who these
folks were saying justice for garrett
foster
uh this was a man uh who was of course
uh at these protests uh
brought an ak-47 for the protest with
intent to use it
a lot of the media won't necessarily
show you this but this is an interview
with garrett foster
before the incident transpired that led
to his untimely demise tell us a little
bit about the gun again
oh it's uh ak-47 you feel like
you'll need to use it nah i think the uh
i mean if i use it against the cops i'm
dead
i think all the people that hate us and
you know want to say to us
[Music]
too big of uh to stop and actually do
anything about it
only turns out not everybody was too big
of a [ __ ] to do something about it
especially
when you aimed your ak-47 at a car
point-blank range now what these people
believe and
what they want you to believe is this
was a guy who was simply out there
protesting peacefully
was run over by his car let me show you
this as i let me show you all of this
right now as i talk about this but
first off i'm a little confused when you
kill the best of us you're left with the
rest of us
i mean the guy writing it is like i'm
i'm just the rest
i'm the shitty guy writing a sign uh
what we do know is that sergeant perry
was not running through protesters
right you can see the damage to his car
the police released
released perry and the other shooter
from this incident in austin
uh let me show you the clip actually
real quick so it's kind of disturbing so
you have some context
now the context that we do know perry
wasn't ramming protesters
he actually was driving for uber he's a
sergeant in the military how do we know
there are receipts there are receipts
that this guy had driven for uber he's
from fort hood
he'd come out to austin because he could
pick up some fares and even had picked
up some fares that night was obeying all
the traffic laws as far
as we know now granted you might hear
some things that are untrue because
it's based on witness testimony namely
witness testimony from people like
antopho and that guy who tried to dress
like the cover of kick-ass too and was
wearing a tactical vest jacket that was
really just cloth because there was
nothing in there
what an [ __ ] right so garrett foster
then approached the vehicle
with his ak-47 what's in question did he
aim it directly at the car
or did he just motion to roll down your
window of sergeant perry in the car
i i don't even know what the motion is
now for rolling
rolling down your window used to be this
but now it's electric is it just
do you do that or if you have an ak is
this i don't know apparently that's what
gary foster thought so
approached the car ak-47 and the man in
the car which was being mobbed
defended himself now i want to be clear
about something here when i say that
garrett foster
deserved it or garrett foster the
shooting was justified is what we
created that sign to say i'm not saying
that garrett foster deserved to die i'm
not someone who's going to be
dancing on the grave putting out i mean
it's sad it's a tragedy
that being said there's a difference
between deserving to die
which is committing a crime punishable
by death and forfeiting your right to
live
garrett foster forfeited his right to
live what do i mean by that when you put
somebody
and this is something that is beyond any
question doesn't matter if garrett
foster was a veteran doesn't matter that
perry was a currently active
member of the military doesn't matter
what garrett foster believes doesn't
matter if perry has some rumors
circulating around there didn't like
black lives matter that is entirely
irrelevant to the fact that when you
approach
a car which is being mobbed by many
people and you can see the damage under
the car here
we don't know some of it was before some
of it was after all of it before all of
it after that remains to be seen but if
you swarm a car
and you aim an ak-47 at somebody in that
car if you don't believe that a human
being in a car
with an ak-47 aimed point-blank range
can defend himself with his firearm
you don't believe that people have the
right to defend themselves that's my
question to you
if not then when when can somebody
defend themselves with a firearm
in their car if someone out there has an
ak
do they have to wait until they actually
get shot is that what you believe the
second amendment to me
is that what you believe stan sends your
ground or defense laws
self-defense laws castle dracula you let
me know when does it become
justified i think it's justified i'm not
saying that i'm glad that garrett foster
died
let's be really clear on that now let's
go around here so you can see this nice
memorial again because they always
create these shrines to known
criminals not like david dorn who we've
talked about you know people who are out
there committing
violent felonies to petty criminality
and this is where you're seeing such a
divide in this country
a lot of people won't even know about
garrett foster most americans know
if they hear the story of garrett foster
oh yeah okay you aimed an ak-47
a guy in a car you got shot that's
unfortunate but it happens but the
people right now who are dying the wool
leftists
who believe that all actions are
justified so long as you're trying to
break down western civilization the
patriarchal system
they see someone like this as a hero
and let me tell you what i mean by uh
forfeiting your right to lift by the way
that's why i have this open carrying
here in austin
no problem now if i remove this from my
holster and aimed it at
let's say that semi truck over there or
let's say i didn't need for the sake of
argument let's use the strongest case
that leftists have i just walked up to
that semi truck right now yeah i can get
a shot of that truck or i could walk
right up to that
expeditionary explorer walked up with my
gun didn't even maybe aiming at the
window maybe aimed at the mirror and
just said
roll down the window uh that might be
more of a problem than it being
holstered
properly forfeiting your right to live
this is a perfect example of it what do
i mean
by that if someone is in fear of their
life
we talked about this with a knockout
game people get knocked out they
go unconscious in the street and they
die they hit their head in the concrete
right
if you mug somebody i don't know that
you just want my wallet i just know that
you're putting a knife to my throat
if you put an ak-47 and you approach a
car and by the way
this person in the car only had one of
two choices
hit the gas forward backwards gonna run
people over
or at least use a gun which is
directional but let me ask let's use the
same standard here
fear for one's life the second you put
someone in mortal fear of their life
you forfeit your right to live we've
heard this arguing about george floyd
again not at all in any way justifying a
knee on the neck but people were saying
this guy was in fear of his life saying
that he couldn't breathe
if you watch the full-length footage now
you see that he was saying he couldn't
breathe when he was
refusing to get into their car but that
was the argument he was in fear of his
life let me ask you this let's use that
standard
who do you believe was more in fear of
their life being taken from them
george floyd if you go and watch that
tape where he says please don't shoot me
man they said we're not going to shoot
you please get out of the car
they said please get into the paddy
wagon he said man i'm claustrophobia
which i think is the name for the new
mixtape he's dropping but they said we
need you to get into the car
he said please stay with me said no
listen we're going to stay with you
we're going to lower the we're going to
roll down the window and turn on the air
if your argument is that george floyd
was in fear of his life
do you think that maybe sergeant perry
with his car being swarmed
after we've seen people dragged from
their vehicles and beat within an inch
of their life and a guy with an ak and a
mask coming up
might also warrant the right to defend
himself
not not a good situation no heroes or
villains i know this is something that
sergeant perry is going to have to live
with for the rest of his life
but how about we stop glorifying people
especially if we want people to be
responsible gun owners which i encourage
we'll be doing some open carries uh
coming up soon so that hopefully
everyone can take part
let's stop glorifying violent criminals
how many times do we have to wait for
the tale of the tape to find out that
someone was acting asshole-ish
and resulted in an unfortunate situation
no one wants any of these folks to die
that's why i recommend
you don't aim an ak at cars you get rid
of the best of us you're
left with the rest of us uh speaking the
best of us if you're actually looking to
you're watching this right now and you
don't want to be banned from youtube or
you don't want to get in trouble online
protect your uh your personal data with
uh
what a vp it's it's expressvpn right
they're they're sponsoring this right
now expressvpn go to expressvpn.com
crowder uh you get uh three months four
years at two months free and a year
membership
three months free expressvpn.crowder so
protect yourself online with expressvpn
and then in real life
just protect yourself by not aiming
ak-47s at cars
baby steps we'll see you later that
seems pretty cut and dry but what do you
think was garrett foster's shooting
justified or is he a modern day martyr
sound off in the comments and be sure to
stay tuned for the full length
change my minds that are coming up
including one next tuesday
on august 11th
[Music]
how old are you
[Music]
i will hear what she has to say